If you really think you would. Care. And then you give me the joy you will get three.
Yeah OK you didn't want to marry the guy. Well and that's why you I'll let you go.
We've got to call it right now what can you do you know. So yeah there was one.
Well you should maybe the way arranged in a way but the way to do you know you when you're hearing.
Good girl with a great idea to come up with.
One of them what they think you always knew you never did you wouldn't be you and you.
You know what we were going to do my wife finally he was right. When she saw it.
What I hear a lot of there are you going to hear you know what you thought I was very relieved
when you could you know why are you going. You know we're going to we're going to get all of this. If you go here.
You know when I was you know with the yeah we you know we've been out here doing them
but they were eventually going to be on the way. You know where they should get out and they do I took anything.
Give me a how about the way that you know. Yeah yeah yeah. Anyway yeah yeah but the key. To. It was one of the.
Just go your little way. Well. You go back to the way you do when they.
But the way to go if you got it wrong all the way because they didn't say oh I just. So there were no you do.
Really anything because I mean most of the life they only know I'm forty one.
Not getting a glass that I get to pick up on it but you may think what you give them.
Or you are going to get three times a day you were both wrong. One day when the day comes. When they want to leave.
You can get away with it on a major wrong with the way you looked at me that way.
What about our the way when we get away with morning. Clean. When we go away. I mean that there are no women.
Look we need to we change some of the thank you. Red light on that guy with a big thank you.
If you get in the way women wearing them and I hear there are more serious. Well you know because the cover.
You don't know where we were that we could have got to get out of the question to get the body with you on the phone.
So you get what you really are. Doing things trying to get them when they are way too many you know.
Well we don't want. Well. They only my way. You know I'm going to. Thank you. Thank you.